le ministre de l'économie du québec
pierre fitzgibbon a annoncé la semaine
dernière la création d'un nouvel
organisme pour encourager la recherche
publique
sa mission favoriser les échanges entre
les milieux de l'enseignement et de la
recherche avec celui des affaires on va
en discuter avec luc sirois il est le
nouveau conseiller stratégique du
ministre de l'économie et de
l'innovation
bonsoir merci d'être là monsieur sirois
bon jeu mais dense et en os alors si on
crée ce nouvel organisme et si on crée
votre poste en maintenant c'est qu'on
veut améliorer les choses est ce que
c'est le constat qu'il ya quelque chose
qui cloche en ce moment vous savez la
recherche publique là c'est une source
incroyable de richesses pour une société
la valorisation de la recherche ça
permet de de créer la valeur économie
ainsi créé la valeur sociale vraiment
pour la société dans son ensemble que la
richesse est créée puis de créer comme
ça un nouvel organisme
c'est avec cette inflexion l'an 2020
c'est toute la société qui en
bénéficient donc la société le
gouvernement devrait s'impliquer
davantage investir davantage et aussi
trouver des façons non seulement de
créer de la richesse économique par la
création de start up par le soutien
d'entreprises industries locales par les
découvertes de chercheurs d'ici mais
aussi la société civile les hôpitaux
l'éducation là toute l'innovation
sociale permet aussi d'améliorer les
choses dans la société et c'est ça fait
partie de la nouvelle mission qu'est ce
qu'on en parle de valorisation de
maximiser la portée économique entre
autres de la recherche publique est-ce
que donc on peut dire qu'elle ne génère
pas assez de retomber en ce moment c'est
on peut toujours aller plus loin il ya
une culture et instaurer de de mettre en
valeur et ça se fait différents niveaux
d'abord il faut que le chercheur est
vraiment un accompagnement soit un plus
présent auprès de ceux qui font la
découverte auprès de ses cerveaux qui
inventent et qui font les nouvelles
technologies pour qu'ils aient aussi le
réflexe de se dire comment valoriser ça
comment amener ça au public comment
faire en sorte que ce soit mieux utilisé
plus
plus utilisés il ya tout ce volet là et
une fois que l'invention et est affiché
là ça permet des entreprises justement
de s'y intéresser et c'est ce maillage
la quittes important de sa part plus
grande quantité les industries ont pas
nécessairement le réflexe naturellement
de l'hiver la recherche publique vers
les chercheurs québécois nos entreprises
pourraient devenir des grands champions
si elle pouvait capitaliser sur toute
cette richesse là qui présente et
comment vous allez vous réussir par
facilité ce maillage entre la recherche
publique et les entreprises
je serai de mille et une façons
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il existe des
pratiques
on a pu observer partout dans le monde
dans des économies très créative très
innovant et pratique un très dynamique
qu'on va amener ici on développe aussi
des meilleures façons que je pense que
un désert qu'est ce que vous allez voir
dans cette société centrale c'est
d'approfondir la compétence pour
comprendre les marchés internationaux
dans les secteurs clients vraiment de la
une quand ou capacités d'analysé de
connexion de compréhension des besoins à
l'international pour pouvoir être
capable d'évaluer la valeur de ces
découvertes et de cette recherche
publique là et de faire le match donc
des sectes une expertise très profonde
sectorielle une présence très accrue
tout un volet aussi d'augmenter la la
disponibilité de ces services là pour
nos centres hospitaliers on au centre de
recherche ce qui m'amène à vous demander
monsieur oui il faut faciliter le
maillage mais aussi s'assurer que les
retombées profitent aux québécois parce
que vous comprendrez c'est de l'argent
public qui finance cette recherche
publique c'est pourquoi que l'argent est
seulement dans les poches d'entreprises
privées tout à fait tout à fait et c'est
ça l'objectif
l'objectif c'est créer de la richesse
pour les québécois à partir de ces
investissements l'accent énorme et qui
sont un peu
moi j'appelle ça nos nouvelles
ressources naturelles si on creuse nos
sols pour trouver des minerais mais
maintenant on creuse nos cerveaux on ne
pourra avoir des découvertes et ça de le
mettre en valeur dans les mains
d'entreprises québécoises qui elles
seront des champions dans le monde
c'est une façon que ça revienne aux
québécois en plus de pouvoir amener ces
innovations là justement dans des
milieux preneur qui le secteur social
ça permet de faire une transformation de
société à partir des meilleures
découvertes qu'on a financé qu'on a
développée ici au québec on sais tu
comment au québec monsieur sirois en
termes de recherche et développement si
on le compare par rapport aux montants
et c est ce qu on est en bonne position
face au reste du monde je devrais sortir
un peu les statistiques mais on est
quand on regarde parc est pour capitale
on est parmi les meilleurs moments
vraiment et c'est on est une terre de de
recherche très intense beaucoup
d'universités
beaucoup de chercheurs au canada à
l'international et les chercheurs c'est
à la fois les professeurs d'université
mais c'est aussi les chercheurs dans les
centres collégiaux
c'est les chercheurs dans les centres
hospitaliers les chercheurs dans les
sentes public on pense à lino ou aux
crimes et tous les étudiants gradués qui
travaillent donc cette masse de
chercheurs là elle est dans l'est
plusieurs les plus nombreuses au canada
et dans l'ombre et en termes de volume
de recherche pour la l'ampleur de notre
nation au total de notre province au
total les widnes parmi les top top 10 au
nombre en espérant pouvoir retenir tous
ces cerveaux là je vous pose une très
courte question en terminant est ce
qu'un lien avec la pandémie pourquoi on
crée cet organisme est là maintenant je
pense que ressortir de la pandémie c'est
un moment où l'on réfléchisse très fort
comme société à comment se réinventer
c'est important de relancer l'économie
avec beaucoup de puissance et
l'innovation c'est un fer de lance pour
la relance justement il pour amener de
la valeur économique rétablir la balance
commerciale pour que nos entreprises
d'ici deviennent les grands exportateurs
et qui soit
millie meilleurs au monde ça va
contribuer à la relance c'est ce qu'on
espère monsieur roy joue seulement deux
chambres dans votre nouveau rôle
ces entreprises et merci à vous tient au
courant
puis on continue d'innover ensemble
merci beaucoup d'action